hey Connor Brian here time for another
clueless gamer tonight I'll be getting a
sneak peek at the upcoming title
Assassin's Creed origins which comes out
October 27th on Xbox one Playstation 4
and PC now I'm really excited cuz I've
got someone very special here to help me
out he's a huge video game nerd himself
two-time NFL MVP Super Bowl champion
quarterback for the Green Bay Packers
mr. Aaron Rodgers so cool dad right away
this you got hit pretty hard playing the
Vikings and walk us through what
happened and we've all seen the team but
I want to make you relive this yeah well
that's my right I threw the ball and I
got tackled and kind of slammed on the
ground but I'm good now thirteen screws
later and Here I am uh thirteen screws
later right I want to show a video of
you getting tackled but NFL won't let us
have the footage and if we did get to
use the footage would be so expensive we
don't have that kind of money
so the closest thing we can do is show
this simulation of what happened to take
I broke my collarbone break your
collarbone I don't know what that means
and I want to understand it precisely
because I'm a precise man mr. bill tall
would you come in here please
this is you yep and point to what was
broken right there okay right around
there
bill would you mind breaking that for us
so that we understand what happened can
you take the skeleton with you he's
gonna leave the skeleton get the thing
out of here this is the creepiest thing
I don't know if you know that about him
I think we should start playing I'm
gonna call in my friend Erin Blair to
help explain get us into the game why do
you always scuttle in like a bug
don't scuttle in like that just walk in
like a guy so this is Assassin's Creed
origins very exciting it's the 10th
anniversary of Assassin's Creed so we're
going back to the very beginning
can we go ahead don't be self-conscious
take place in ancient Egypt and we're
going back to the very beginning of the
franchise now Assassin's Creed as I'm
sure you know and you guys know it's
basically present-day but your reach a
person who's reliving the memory of
their ancestors so through a thing
called the animus so that
does that make sense to you nope I don't
get a word of it I don't understand and
I get self-conscious because I think
it's me when you explain these things
it's gibberish we're exploring the
beginning of the assassins Brotherhood
now the assassins Brotherhood is a group
that throughout history
I can see I can actually hear at this
moment
Aaron's bones knitting this gibberish oh
my god that's the gun the Vikings that
tackled you look at him okay hold on how
am i doing so far here look at I like to
see the country before I funny
he's never fought someone like me before
what did I do
what am i suddenly what happened there's
sorry I went into God mode because she
pressed both sticks what does that mean
god mode his mode where you can't be
hurt it looked like suddenly I was in a
open air Music Festival yeah and that
guy's almost dead
[Applause]
building an ubisoft wish to make it very
clear the monkey just some little
stone-cold badass assassin that's around
like a giant computer it's not available
in the actual game this is what is known
as god mode which is never used by the
developers of Assassin's Creed origins
only it was never meant for average
schlubs like Conan to see we have no
idea how we manage to press the right
buttons and the right sequence on the
controller to Texas exactly if you
didn't anticipate Conan having the over
typical coordination
[Applause]
sorry-sorry party coming through oh I
need that guy can this be the whole game
just base was called grand theft chariot
you look strong and carry yourself
without fear and you help a poor farmer
your friend was killed by a hippo this
is cool we've just been joined by your
teammate David buck Thierry
good to have you here your job then is
to protect your job to protect him yes
David I would like to know where you
were when Aramis we bring the skeleton
back in now where were you this is Erin
where were you when Aaron was hit in
relation to this skeleton this is Erin
this is Erin I was just standing please
go to where you were
I can't go any further so you were back
way dudes close you were there like
almost arms like you were that way
almost nobody I was beyond this save it
David I don't want to tell you how to do
your job we would like an explanation
this can work oh wait he's fixing it hey
Dad hey you [ __ ] you're fine
a good friend of mine he's been working
on the show as a producer almost since
the beginning Jason Shalini come in
Jason would you come in Jason have you
met everybody here Jason Aaron you have
fantasy football team W big time man
okay who was your quarterback yeah how
are you doing before he got hurt I lost
two in a row well would you like to
apologize
not little all right here we go
these guys play in a stadium their true
real-life gladiators we thought we'd go
into an arena right now oh now you think
that would be fatal
yeah kill him de village enemy he's got
him he's got him this is your chance yes
come on that's it cut it [ __ ] off yep no
baby no mercy no mercy why did you let
him guide you over say I'm Mario I got
really nervous I just press that yeah
you let him live you don't seem to have
the killer what are you show mercy say
something I think your natural instinct
is compassion compassion peace and I
think that's what got this man I think
when I think when you're up against
another player you're just like hey man
that's what you want to do if you want
to go get air and go get Aaron because
that's
[Applause]
yeah would you agree to counseling
Dave agrees okay he's still gonna get
counseling cuz that's really
[Applause]
you